قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان دول
الناتو ستصبح اثنتين دوله بعد ان اوفى
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ببعده
بالموافقه على انضمام السويد للحلفا واتهم
بايدن في كلمه له في ختام قمه الناتو ودول
السبعه الكبرى في العاصمه الليتوانيه
اتهام روسيا بانها لا تؤمن بالعلاقات
الدبلوماسيه وقال ان الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين ضمن ان بامكانه جر النيتو الى حرب
لكن الحلفاء رد بالتركيز على جاهزيته
للدفاع عن اي من اعضائه واكد ان قوه
الناتو لا يمكن الاستهانه بها وان بوتين
اخطا عندما ظن ان الحلفه سيتفكك وجدد
بعيدا الالتزام بالدفاع عن امن اوكرانيا
وتوفير الدعم اللامحدود لها في الحرب
واضاف الرئيس الامريكي ان الاوكرانيين لم
يستسلموا وضلوا صامدين وان الحلف لا
يتراجع او يتساهل في الد فاع عن اوكرانيا
مشددا كذلك على عدم التخلي عن دول البلطيق
وعن الروابط القويه معها